Speaker 1: All right, everybody, let's get
to this week's mailbag.
An increasingly popular segment, people seem
to be loving this segment other than the people
who hate it.
And that's about, I don't know, judging from
my email, it's not a zero.
It's a non-zero number of people know.
But we keep getting more and more e-mails
and interesting things.
So let's just get right into it first.
Message from Moose.
Moose, says Mr. Pacman sir.
While eating lunch in the teacher's lounge
today, I overheard some coaches discussing
the new vaccine in China with a 58 percent
fatality rate.
The conversation quickly went into one of
the coaches telling everyone China's working
on a vaccine to get rid of our sight and hearing
because they already created COVID, which
damaged our taste and smell.
I long blinked and face palmed.
What are your thoughts?
Obviously, it's all bonkers, but what's interesting
about that is they seem to concede COVID was
created to damage our taste and smell.
So now they're going to make a vaccine to
get rid of our sight and hearing.
But I thought the problem with COVID was the
vaccine, not the virus.
I thought the point was the vaccine kills
you.
As you can see there, various conspiracy theories
that COVID was created to take away our dam
to damage our taste and smell, but that the
vaccine, which prevents that for many people
actually is what kills you.
But then now they're going to do a new quote
vaccine in order to take take people's sight
and hearing it's all completely incoherent.
It's all absolute and complete nonsense.
It doesn't make any sense.
And yet this type of stuff keeps spreading.
I wonder where Moose maybe moose is a sign
that Moose is in, you know, some part of the
country with with moose.
And that's where you got a lot of teachers
who believe this stuff, I don't know would
be interesting to know what school district
that is.
But those those people are teaching some of
your kids, some of your kids are being taught
by those folks.
That is horrifying.
That is absolutely and completely horrifying.
Next email is from Bill.
Bill says Ask this question Does Steve Scalise
believe that his own election was legitimate?
Same ballots.
Same election?
Yeah, this is something I pointed out.
I think it was in December, which is you've
got all these people saying the results of
the presidential election were bogus.
Bogus can't be trusted.
They're fake, fraud, whatever.
But all of the other races on the same ballots,
like the senators and the members of Congress
and all that stuff.
Those are fine.
How exactly did they pull that off?
And that would have been.
This is a reference to the interview that
Chris Wallace did with Steve Scalise that
we looked at last week or Chris Wallace was
saying, Did Trump win or was it stolen from
him?
Did Trump win?
Was it stole from, you know, all this type
of stuff?
Did Biden win or was it stolen from him?
And Steve Scalise basically answered the question
three or four different ways, none of which
were actually direct answers.
A great question would be were there also
the same degree of irregularities and possible
fraud in your election, Steve Scalise, because
you were on those same ballots and I don't
know what he would say.
He'd probably have some kind of workaround
would be by my prediction.
Next email is from Chase Chase, says David.
Audits are OK.
Why not allow all those demanding audits to
have their way?
But first, they have to agree to some requirements.
Number one, they must cover all audit expenses,
including for experienced objective observers
to counting must be done in publicly viewed
areas.
Another number two must agree to no access
to personal voter information, nor voter machine
tampering.
And number three, which is really number four,
if they find verifiable significant fraud,
then the taxpayers will reimburse all reasonable
expenses.
This would force them to put up or shut up.
It sort of would chase, but the problem is
that they would they would still fundraise
for it.
So we, as they have been doing and Trump was
able to raise tens of millions saying, we're
going to use this money to fight voter fraud
and the like.
So I don't really know that that would be
the solution to bogus audits.
The the bigger issue is what does it even
really mean to do an audit?
And that's a word that's often used, which
has different meanings or no meaning at all,
depending on where it's taking place.
And so I think it's a bigger systemic problem,
but I don't disagree that saying you've got
to pay is a good idea.
In some cases they have paid, or at least
they funded the process themselves.
It hasn't really deterred too much.
But certainly there should be a financial
disincentive from doing this unless they,
you know, really, really believe it, which
many of them, I know don't.
It could serve to dissuade some of this nonsense
behavior.
Next email today is from Adrian.
Adrian writes in About Autocracy, Fascism
and Republicans and says, I watch your channel,
I watch Twitter and others.
I also occasionally look at the opposite views
to give myself perspective smart thing to
do.
I'm becoming more and more worried about 2022
and 2024.
We've become rather comfortable in our post
in a World post-World War Two.
But should we can we say for sure that a new
Nazi party will never happen again?
Look at the Grand Old Party, meaning the Republican
Party and those within it who have always
been there.
But due to Trump and his rhetoric now feel
they have the license to spout their true
nature as if it was commonplace should make
those of us with any semblance of decency
shudder with fear.
Yeah, this this is a good point and I've said
many times before.
Anybody who who has the idea X can never happen
or X can never happen again.
Needs to rethink that and be more cautious.
Hopefully certain things won't happen or won't
happen again.
But listen, you know, when Trump said at the
State of the Union a couple of times, we will
never be a socialist country.
Maybe we will.
Unpredictable things happen and how Trump
can say the US will never be socialist.
What about in 100 years?
What about 500 years?
We don't know that and much the same way for
people who say Nazi ism, Hitler stuff could
never happen again, assuming it couldn't.
It's part of what could allow it to.
And that's why all of this drama and delusion
related to the Jan. six riots and the slow
motion coup that now is being discussed more
and more cannot be ignored should not be ignored.
And that's part of why we continue to talk
about it, Andrew wrote in about the microchip
shortage and says, Sirs, so much has been
made of the current microchip shortage, and
I can't believe the nonsense that is being
spread misinformation about shipping issues.
This is satire, by the way, and manufacturing
backlogs is reaching ridiculous proportions.
It's very simple.
Every vaccine has a microchip, and now every
booster will have one as well.
This is why there is a microchip shortage.
Wake up, sheeple.
It's sad, but even though I'm telling you,
this is satire.
I will get comments just if you're if you're
watching this on YouTube right now.
Look down below, you'll see comments that
don't realize that that's satire.
It's satire, it's a joke.
It's poking fun at the disinformation, anti-vaxxers.
All right, everybody relax.
It's just satire.
Trust me, it's satire.
Look, Ian wrote in.
Lukin says, David, you've been repeatedly
accused of being quote bought by Big Pharma.
This is, of course, unsubstantiated nonsense.
An interesting response, I believe, could
be for you to share the following stories
of how YouTubers around the world are being
paid to promote anti-vax conspiracies, which
is literally the opposite of what you are
accused of.
Yeah.
Without evidence and without even plausibility,
people accuse me of being in the pocket of
Big Pharma.
I'm getting money from Big Pharma to promote
the vaccine now.
All I've ever done is report the data and
the statistics on vaccine studies.
But there actually are anti-vaccine influencers
and money floating around to them to question
the efficacy of the vaccines to promote alternative
treatments as if they are ironclad treatments
for COVID.
On and on and on, that's actually where the
money is.
Why would anyone pay me to quote, promote
a vaccine?
The data says it really protects you from
serious illness and death.
We see the overwhelming number of deaths among
the unvaccinated.
I really went and got the vaccine.
Nobody paid me to go and get it.
Why would anyone pay me to promote the vaccine?
It doesn't make any sense, nor is there evidence
that people are being paid to promote it.
There is evidence people are being paid to
promote anti-vax ideas.
Sometimes it's soft anti-vaxxer ism, which
is talking about disproportionately focusing
on side effects or talking about there's plenty
of alternative treatments, etc.
Sometimes it's straight up anti-vax like conspiracy
theory, microchip 5G.
Your arm gets magnetized sort of stuff.
There's a combination of both.
They're the ones that we know, some of whom
have gotten paid next email.
I love this.
Oh, David, you lie so much.
It's scary.
No wonder your channel is dying.
I really love these because it's so not true,
and it angers them that the channels aren't
dying we actually had last week.
This is I don't even know why this is happening.
We had the best week last week for the audio
podcast since the week of the insurrection.
You've got to go back ten and a half months
for a week where we had the same number of
audio podcast downloads as last week.
The audio podcast has been exploding.
We have more subscribers than ever.
On YouTube, we reached 1.4 million.
I'm really excited about getting to one point
five million.
We had something like 30 million YouTube views
last month.
Extremely healthy number.
And these folks have been around for a long
time.
Oh, you're circling the drain any day now
you're going to have you're going to be down
to zero viewers.
The show has never been bigger, and it's a
really exciting thing to see.
All right, one last bonus message this one's
from Facebook.
This one is from an unnamed, an individual
whom I shall not name, who says you need to
stop pushing lies.
You're accusing this woman of lying.
You are the liar.
The vaccine has not been approved.
You might as well move to Venezuela or Nazi
Germany.
If that's what you think, I think it would
be best for you to shut up.
Not a single punctuation mark, not a single.
Well, I guess the apostrophe in your and that's
count.
Not a single comma, not a single period.
Just a run on.
This is the run on from hell, I guess, is
what I would say.
And it's kind of funny.
Also Venezuela or Nazi Germany, both regimes
which I oppose for different reasons and which
have very little in common with each other.
Sad stuff.
Sad stuff, my friends.
Get your emails in for the mailbag info at
David Pakman dot com info at David Pakman
dot com.
But and this is a really serious thing.
Please don't e-mail us every day.
Please don't e-mail us multiple times a day.
There are now probably about 50 people in
the audience who relentlessly email us every
single day about things related to politics
and things not related to politics.
If you're doing that, we almost certainly
are not seeing your emails.
When we see someone does this stuff emailing
in a dozen times a day, sometimes more, and
they clog our inbox.
It really restricts our ability to go through
and find substantive material.
So those are getting filtered directly into
the trash and just just think, Am I emailing
David every day?
Am I emailing David multiple times a day?
If you are, we're not seeing it.
We're almost certainly not seeing the messages
because they're just being auto filtered.
We just we just can't keep up with that.
It's not what the mailbag and what the email
address is set up for.
You know, it's let's let's let's be sensible,
my friends, let's be sensible.
Email is info at David Pakman dot com.
We have a phenomenal bonus show for you today.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com to get internet
access, and we've got a whole
Unidentified: new week of shows coming up
for the next to the well.